Let me show you the delicious dinner I made
for my family of six using these little 10 inch pans.
I first started out with this
almost 2 pound flat iron steak
and it was very thick,
but I was still able to get a nice crust on the outside
because these pans heat amazingly and evenly.
And then with just a wet paper towel,
I was able to wipe out all the crust
and char from cooking that steak,
which usually a pan would have to soak to do that,
but it just wipes out like nothing.
And I'm able to move on to the next item.
I, while the steak was resting,
I heated up some garlic butter
shrimp from the freezer
and then it was time to cut up the steak.
And look how beautifully that thing was cooked
on the inside.
Nice and pink,
medium, but fully cooked.
And that's it,
dinner was served.
I just got one pan dirty,
combined it with some salad,
some rolls and trust me,
everybody was very full,
very satisfied,
and I only had one pan to clean.
If you wanna get a set of these pans,
which I highly recommend,
the link is right here in the video.